Hi V I love how easy it is to build web
apps with Cloud run I don't have to
worry about server provisioning or
maintenance yes I've met with many
developers here in Europe who say the
same things but some large retailers
here in the US have asked me what
happens when Black Friday or another
traffic Spike happens can Cloud runs
scale up quickly enough absolutely let's
find out by running an
[Music]
experiment
all right vza how will this experiment
work I build a simple Club run service
and this is what it does when it gets a
request it will wait for one second and
then compute a few prime numbers it's a
healthy mix of iio weight and CPU
usage okay uh but V is this actually a
good example I don't know of many
customers who computing prime numbers in
production yeah you're you're absolutely
right a better example would look like
this to handle a request your service
likely sends a request to a back end
waits for the response and then Burns a
few CPU Cycles to process the response
ah I get what you're trying to say uh
your example is similar to real world
Services uh because it's also a mix of
waiting and CPU usage uh do you also
have a database that you sending queries
to here no I I don't my service handles
every request by waiting for one second
and Computing a few prime numbers to to
burn CPU cycles and in the real world
the whole system needs to scale
including the database but this demo is
just about scaling Cloud run all right
sounds great vza and now you're going to
send some traffic to your Cloud run
service right that's right and and this
is how I'm going to do it I'll use an
infinite Loop to send requests to my
servers and in fact I'll use many
infinite Loops that's great I'm usually
not a fan of infinite Loops uh but they
sound very useful here uh how will we
see the results of this low test well
I've built a small dashboard and it will
show all those infinite Loops visualized
as red circles and all those infinite
Loops send requests to the club run
service Club run starts container
instances to handle the requests and I
visualized the container instances using
uh green squares that looks great uh how
do you know when each container starts
and stops in my code I sent a message to
pups up when the container is ready to
receive requests and I also send a
signal when it's about to shut down and
that does mean that there might be a
small lag in the visualization before
you see the container instance light up
in the interface well that's the
container instance startup time okay got
it uh when the clients are sending
requests we won't see the container
instances immediately uh because Cloud
run has to start them first
that sounds reasonable uh now shall we
start the load test yes let's get
started here is my load tester tool
there are four buttons at the top we are
now at no traffic um there's regular
traffic a traffic Surge and insane
traffic and I'm not sure I want to press
that today but well I will do it
anyway all right and uh there's also a
total number of requests and success
percentage now that success percentage
that's an important number to watch
right yeah yeah that's right it would be
really great if the success percentage
stays at 100% because that will mean the
club run successfully handled every
single request now let's start the test
and click regular
traffic okay 10 infinite Loops appear
and they start sending requests Club run
needs just a few container instances to
serve this
load and you can you can see the counter
increase too that counts the total
number of of requests
served all right we we've served about
500 requests now let's simulate a
traffic surge now and increase the
number of infinite Loops from 10 to
2,000 and Cloud run is deciding what to
do now the current active instances
don't have enough capacity to serve all
incoming requests immediately so
requests start to queue up in the system
and as an end user you will notice some
additional latency now
and there you go Club run decides to add
many more container instances to serve
all those incoming
requests so you're saying that Clon
starts new container instances to handle
incoming requests why then are there
more low generating clients than there
are container instances oh that's a
great question it's because each
container instance handles many requests
at the same time Club run looks at the
CPU utilization and the rate of incoming
requests to add more instances ah got it
hey V uh I noticed that you didn't push
the last button yet I'm sure everyone
who's watching uh wants to see what
happens when you do that yes I'm I'm not
sure I'm ready for that but I will press
it anyway and this will increase the
number of clients from 2,000 to 30,000
and those are infinite Loops right not
end users okay I will I will I will
press the
button
wow look at the number of container
instances and still a 100% success rate
and that's kind of the important thing
here uh it looks like Cloud Ron scales
up quickly when your traffic
increases yes but remember if your Cloud
run service hits a database you need to
make sure that the database can keep up
with this sort of traffic in practice I
think many developers will find that
cloud run won't limit the scalability of
their
system right right uh good point uh
let's leave database scalability for
another video uh but handling all this
traffic can't be free yeah that's right
it's not free to keep many container
instances running and that reminds me I
should turn off the load tester now this
test didn't take long so it should have
only cost me a few
dollars the good news is that by default
you only pay for instances in Cloud run
while they are handling requests well
thank you for showing us how quickly
Cloud round scales up V you're welcome I
think this experiment gave us a good
idea of how Cloud run scales up and
everyone has to decide for themselves if
this would be quick enough for their
system yeah well it would certainly be
quick enough for any system I've built
well workloads are different so everyone
has to make their own decisions based on
their situation that is a good point
Pizza well thank you everyone for
watching if you have any questions for V
or me about Cloud Run scalability please
let us know in the comments also do let
us know if there are any other servess
topics you'd like to see in future
episodes we read every single comment
until next
[Music]
time